i've seen this movie 50 times before
and i know that if you go this way or if
you go that way
you know so the smart routers go this
way like you only get that from
experience
[Music]
jeff hyman thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders
thanks for having me really really great
to have you you know you had such
interesting positions
in the legal space but also in the hr
space so i believe
you you started the you were the general
counsel and you started the hr at pebble
technology which i love i backed both
kickstarters
incredible then you were senior director
at google
advisor to several companies i think
boosted boards was one of them
yeah i it's one of my dreams it's one of
my life goals to be able to write on the
boosted board but i'm terrified
so maybe you'll ease my concern and
you're an adjunct professor
at santa clara university teaching about
the legal aspect of startups
jeff what does that mean what does that
mean the legal aspect of startups
well in the course at the law school
what we do is
i try to present to the students what
the arc of legal issues are that
startups
face from you know formation to raising
capital and dealing with vcs
and then you know key issues about
contracts and
hiring people and employment law issues
and then
ultimately you're working towards uh
m a and going public right and
throughout it
the focus of the class is really about
you know educating the students a bit
on some of the key legal issues at every
one of those steps but it's really about
how do you function in a startup
as a lawyer and what's the most useful
way to be a partner
to all of the other you know business
stakeholders in a company in charting
solutions to navigate through all those
legal issues
so take me through this take take me
through this life cycle from
you know you're joining at pebble as a
very early employee right i think 35th
employee
what does that mean being you know being
a good partner
at an early stage startup and then
taking me through the journey of the
startup up until the ipo
so i think yeah so it and i think it's
really that
it's an important distinction between
being like a law firm lawyer
or even working in a big company legal
department like i did
at intel or apple where you know when
when you're a huge company you have
so much at stake so much at risk
uh and a lot to protect and to worry
about
and what a lot of those companies legal
practices are really about is
identifying
and managing risk whereas
in a startup you have you have
very little to protect and it's really
about
you know you're trying to do something
new and you're trying to create and
build
right so the orientation i think there
is and this certainly
it was my attitude when i got to pebble
you show up and there is no legal
department there's nothing
and there's a business that's trying to
accomplish something
and really your job as the general
counsel
or legal counsel is understand what the
business is trying to do
and figure out how can you help make
that happen
and along the way how do you help build
the company
and make sure that the company is making
really smart choices
about how it's you know pursuing those
those business opportunities in a smart
way how it's
complying with the laws that it needs to
comply with
or at least making really informed
choices when it's not
and sometimes that's that's part of what
startups have to do
too but then also being really smart
about
you know particularly in a technology
startup you have a great idea
and now you're executing to it how do
you do that in a way that's going to be
protectable
so that you have a differentiated
advantage and you're able to protect
that differentiation sometimes through
intellectual property sometimes through
how you set up contracts and
relationships with external
parties et cetera so i mean you're
there's a lot
yeah and i mean you know looking at the
background so besides being
a part of the of you know these huge
companies very successful companies
you've taken a very active role within
those you know more
uh internet of things devices like
wearable technology
like the booster boards so i'm guessing
there the ip plays a pretty strong part
right because especially today
you know you you create some new
wearable device and all of a sudden you
know across the sea on the east
you have you have companies doing almost
the same thing for much cheaper
so so what are the different challenges
there that you've seen with these
different companies that you've worked
with
well that's and that's really i think
especially in the hardware
space and that's really one of the big
challenges you can have
if you look at like a pebble watch or
you know i have the same thought
when gopro came out with their camera
when you tear those devices down
they're just made up full of commodity
off-the-shelf
parts right that anybody can you know
tear it open and
and copy it and and if they can offer it
at a lower price because they have
cheaper labor whatever the case may be
you're in big trouble yeah so if you
want to have
something that's going to give you a
sustained differentiated
advantage to compete you've got to bring
something that isn't so easy to knock
off
and and what what are those things well
at pebble one of the things that
that we had was we had software we had a
you know a distinct ui we had a set of
software features we had a really uh
you know impressive uh back-end you know
cloud-based systems we had
i actually developed i yeah i i
developed apps for my pebble yeah
yeah so like those are the kinds of
things that if you're smart about how
you do it those can start to create
moats
that that will defend your
your competitive advantage so long as
people like the product
right and ultimately all these things
they all devolve down to the basic
question of
are you doing something that consumers
want
that's the ultimate you know your
challenge
but i think that you can you can be
smart about how you decide you know
whether you're going to try to protect
things through patents and there's a
there's criteria and strategies around
figuring out that
there's also a lot of strategy around
when there are things that
are actually hard about what makes your
product work or how you
assemble your product and if you keep
those things secret
um you can give yourself some advantage
as well so how you maintain your trade
secrets is
important so there's lots of different
strategies and and law plays a part
of figuring out how how effective a moat
can you build around the business
and then how does that play though into
you know your role as leading the hr
at a company like pebble because in my
mind legal and hr don't necessarily go
hand in hand
so it's really yeah it's really
interesting when i joined the pebble
the first day i i showed up there was a
recruiter and he asked me to go into a
conference room and he said
hey you know you're also in charge of hr
there's some things that you need to
know about
and so it's it isn't actually
that strange because the intersection
you know there's a lot of
of hr that's really about
not only complying with a whole host of
employment laws which are really
important
but a lot of those laws are there when
you think about it to
to protect and promote the interests of
the team
and the employees and and when you think
in a startup about what's something
that's really important well it's the
team
and the culture of the company and so
for me
i i had a really natural
interest and passion for doing the hr
work i still love
doing it and i was really i was thrilled
to
get to wear both of those hats because
sometimes when you're doing the legal
work it can be a little isolating
from you know the team writ large and
you're doing things that
are important but maybe don't resonate
with everybody
when you work in hr you're doing stuff
that affects everybody
all the time and the feedback loop is
instantaneous you hear from
people all the time which i which i
enjoy most of the time
i love it i love it okay now you know
i'm going to be starting a startup
hopefully sooner rather than later
and how how can i as a founder as an
entrepreneur i know nothing about legal
how can i even go and approach you know
doing things the right way and
understanding
and and really complying with the right
things but also thinking strategically
about protecting the stuff that i'm
doing
is do i bring somebody in house do i go
outside to a different company
you know sort of what's the best
practices with your insight over years
in this industry
well now what you're going to do is call
me okay okay
it's done that's it so that's it's funny
because that's really what
the this consulting business that i run
now is really
in a way it's sort of my my solution to
the problem that you just raised
is right when you're when you're
starting out and
it's early days it it doesn't make sense
to hire a full-time
lawyer at a really early stage startup
but there are so many things that even
in the early stages
that founders want to get right and they
need
it they're not intuitive you know most
founders are technical
sometimes they're sales or marketing
oriented people but there's
no reason to assume that you would have
this very specialized knowledge
and kind of the wisdom of experience to
know
what are some of the better solutions
you know than others
so you can read a lot on the web and i
think a lot of founders do and some of
it's good and some of it's not
yeah there's lots and lots of law firms
you can go to
and you know law firms are are great at
if you
go to a good one there's a lot of
subject matter knowledge but there isn't
always a lot of practical wisdom
and sort of street smarts and so
ultimately
i think what you want as a founder is to
say okay
you know tell me don't just tell me what
the law is
but tell me practically what's the
smartest
way to get from where i am to where you
understand i want to go
and i think that's really what makes for
a great
in-house lawyer or even somebody like me
who's a part-time gc
and head of hr for lots of startups well
somebody who brings that perspective up
in reality
like you're always weighing risk
against benefit right and sometimes
you know it can be expensive to comply
with every single
detail or to try to tackle all the
problems at once
and you have to prioritize so having
that practical
experience to know like what do i really
need to do right now
what can weight what's like what's a
good enough solution
versus you know the cadillac and you
don't always need the cadillac
that's that's really the kind of
practical experience that
that you need but even in you know in
especially in legal when you you have to
specialize in a lot of these things and
especially when you're talking about
intellectual property
you ha it sounds like you almost have to
be to be somewhat of an expert on the
technology that this company is
developing and
you're going from you know smart watches
to
you know electro electric scooter boards
to google intel apple
how do you how do you understand the
technology and how much how much of a
deep dive do you actually need to have
within each of these realms in order to
be giving really good advice
well it's really it's one of the things
that's really fun about
working in the valley is if you're
interested
in technology and in business which i
i am both of those you know as well as
the law
i've had a lot of people i've worked
with say that
you know i'm a business person who
happens also to be a lawyer
and i try to think of it that way too so
you know over a number of years you work
on a lot of different kinds of things
and you learn from
hopefully really smart mentors and
practitioners
but then yeah you do have to learn the
technology because it
it can be relevant sometimes and
sometimes it's not i mean
to help address you know employment law
issues
uh it's not necessary that you know much
about
the business or the product or the
technology
but if you're but certainly when you're
thinking about intellectual property
matters
or even you know structuring
partnerships with outside
companies particularly if it involves
like manufacturing or licensing
technologies
you do need to understand at some level
you don't have to be an engineer
but the more you understand i think it
can it can help you
a lot definitely and you know so you
know looking over all these companies
and all these years in your industry
what are some of the common pitfalls
that you see founders or entrepreneurs
make along the way that that
could be avoided you know i'm looking at
myself things that i'm i want to write
down
that i want to make sure that i do
things right as i go along my own
entrepreneurial journey
gosh you know there's every
startup that i've worked with and i'm
working with
four companies right now they all
struggle with a lot of people related
issues
a lot of employment law issues
interesting
and i think they also struggle with
the you know how to build and manage
teams and do some of the compensation
strategy like all of that people related
stuff
is a challenge and that's partly because
none of it's intuitive
at all like there's nothing intuitive
about employment law
it's detailed and in california it's
shocking and surprising what the law
actually
requires it's it's very unclear to both
sides right both the employer and the
employee
it can be it absolutely can be and there
can be a tremendous amount of um a
problem when the relationship goes south
you know and and that can happen right
so
so getting a lot of those people related
issues right is
is a challenge i think also um
that when when founders early on
start engaging with the outside world
whether it's through contracts or
through collaboration
talking about technology or developing
technology with outsiders
uh getting that right both in terms of
the contracts that the companies
are signing and the contracts that
they're not signing
and putting in place is sort of another
area where i see a lot of
opportunity to benefit from working with
someone who can
you know guide you through that um i
think there's
naturally there's a desire to like
you know you see a problem you want to
go solve it and there's a smart person
or
a company that's got some technology
that's that's interesting let's just
dive in and solve the technical problem
but but if you don't set that up right
and especially sometimes before the work
begins
you can really be creating some
difficult you know problems that you're
gonna have to dig out of
uh you know after the fact 100 is it
very common in your industry to go
you know broad and be in like for four
companies at the same time or
do you know people at your caliber
usually go and do a deep dive into one
company it you know it it's a mix i
think
yeah i mean clearly what i'm doing i
think is not the conventional
path i mean i've done being part of of
big companies and smaller ones full-time
by the way what's the difference in that
so you know being
being in huge companies like google and
then being in small companies like
pebble
like do give me a little bit of a taste
of of how different it is from your
perspective
well so so if you think about the time
that i was at apple
i was part of the hardware legal team
and within the whole legal team you know
there was the software legal team and
there was internet services which at the
time was you know itunes and the
bookstore and
all of that and then there was the
privacy team and the litigation team and
the patent team and
all these and so the whole point though
is you start getting
specialization and a more narrow focus
so
even you know while i was a senior
person and ultimately led the hardware
legal team at apple
i had nothing to do with all the really
interesting things that apple was doing
and software and services
and it's completely cool ways of setting
up the apple stores and
how apple was selling i had nothing to
do with that yeah
so that focus and specialization and
sort of staying in your lane
is sort of the hallmark of working in a
big legal department
and i had done that kind of work for a
long time i didn't tell an apple and i
was desperate to get out of that
you know narrow lane and have the breath
of all the issues and also
you know when you're at an intel or an
apple it's like a
giant aircraft carrier and it
it it will be just fine whether you're
there or not and it
turns very slowly i wanted to go to an
early stage company
where whether i showed up to work or not
and the work that i was doing was
actually going to make an important
you know value impact to to the company
um and so that that's really what led me
to
to go to pebble and have my first
startup experience
and i've worked with you know many
startups since then
what i like about you know playing the
role i play now
as a sort of a part-time gc and right
of hr is you get to
um you know you get an exposure and you
know at any one time you've got this
group of companies you're working with
so there's really
interesting variety different
technologies all my companies are very
very different from each other in their
focus
and you get this breadth of
people and experiences and you you're
constantly learning and then you can
take
those lessons and apply them you know
across
all the companies so you know instead of
being
you know all of my experience is what
it's like to work at pebble
i actually now have the experience of
having worked with i think
you know eight or nine different
startups over the past few years with a
detour to be a business executive at
google in between
um and so i i just love it it's fun and
the
variety is there and um
i i i just really enjoy it quite a bit i
mean you're almost like a walking ai
machine because you have all this data
in your head about all these different
companies and i'm guessing some things
are
are starting to come up they say yeah
well i've seen something similar a few
years ago at this company
which you know and that just transcends
every experience that
you know somebody can get in university
or or reading in a textbook because you
actually lived through
crises you lived you've lived through
successes and you've seen all the
different complexities of these problems
i mean you hear investors talk about
pattern recognition yes and
you know it's it's the same thing and
that's really
and it's it's funny because one of the
things that you constantly hear about
in the valley is sometimes founders
greatly discount the value of experience
you know they build a team and they're
like
just just give me somebody who's smart
and enthusiastic and they can be great
and sometimes that's right but that
pattern recognition
and the wisdom of knowing you know when
this kind of problem has come up
i've seen this movie 50 times before
and i know that if you go this way or if
you go that way
you know so the smart routers go this
way like you only get that from
experience
and so what's fun now is to be able to
operate
with that experience and be able to you
know apply that wisdom
of experience and it's really beneficial
for companies and it's kind of a
it's a thrill to kind of you're
presented with a problem and you're able
to
offer this perspective and and to the
founders most of the time
they're really really appreciative of
that and that's also the kind of thing
that even the law firm lawyers i think
struggle with
i'm sure they're they're much more you
know doctrinal
and they're still in the business of
identifying risk
because no law firm ever wants to be in
a position where
something bad happens at a company and
you go back to the law firm and say you
didn't tell me about this you didn't
warn me about that so they're
really in the business of warning and
risk mitigation
whereas i'm more in the business of
saying
how do we move the company forward but
also navigate around or through
some of these legal issues i love it
okay so jeff expect a call from me
hopefully in less than a few years for
my startup
but before that i need three words that
best describe you
all right i'm gonna go with optimistic
all right determined a lawyer saying
optimistic interesting yeah
yeah yeah yeah um determined
and i think the third one would be
evolving
i love it i love it very much and and
and jeff i i i'm really glad to be
learning
all this from you and and we're both you
know involved with j ventures and
and it you know i just love how i get to
be exposed to all these incredible
people like yourself
and so thank you for everything that
you're teaching me and i look forward to
continue collaborating in the fund
and i look forward to working together
in the future that'd be great
thanks a lot it's a lot of fun thank you
take care bye